Shahzad Matisse to play presenting our
stylist Anthony Rapp Mary Wiseman who
plays cadet Julian Tilly James screams
who played ambassador Sarek don't go
between lieutenant
Saru jingle Isaac
and last but not least first officer
Michael Burnham played by an equal
marking grade
this is so exciting we have a lot of
questions here many of them were sent in
from the internet webs thank you very
much for sending in your questions we've
got a lot of people in a very short
amount of time we want to get as many
questions going as possible so I'm going
to throw it right off Shaniqua how you
doing I'm doing a gorgeous evening what
was the first thing you did when you
learned you got the part of Michael
Burnham and was joining the Star Trek
franchise you know the moment that I got
the call I was actually in when Assad is
with us we might have been his but if we
were at a restaurant and I it's recorded
he recorded it for me and I went like
this and then I am and I shed a few
tears as well tears - yeah
fantastic that's exciting and this is a
question off of the Internet webs for
Alex what were the biggest challenges
advance of balancing our modern
technological world with the mid 1960s
aesthetic of the original series because
this show takes place ten years before
the original series and you have so much
so many advances in technology and CGI
and special effects and how to marry
those two worlds it seems like an
impossible task yeah I think I think we
were all we we are all the hugest fans
of the original series so we're taking a
tremendous amount of our inspiration
from it and obviously we want to be
accurate we are within Canon
there are raging debates all day in the
writers room
among all the writers and the producers
about what is within Canada without you
can of what can we use what we do
technically so we've been very
consistent with that at the same time we
have to recognize that we are now in an
age where we gave you four walls said
you would not be very happy particularly
since you have to pay for the show so we
are we are constantly this debate but
yes you will see as you can tell if you
guys like that so tough domestic it's a
little bit larger than the original
series in terms of scope and scale and
but we are we are very consistent with
the with our origins fantastic
Jason hahaha there John you doing
well I understand you were shooting some
episodes of Star Trek in between tennis
games up in Toronto great getting
schooled by your good self a little bit
there's been a lot of cafes in the Star
Trek universe
how does captain Lorca different since
the idea where members of the audience
may be under 18 years of age am i
laughing clear so I'm not allowed to say
that he's probably more [ __ ] up in any
of them
he's a complicated guy to complicated
story for our times you know when
felting was made originally 60s there
were some enormous shifts and changes
going on the world in this room and also
reflects that too and the character and
he's uh he's the guy whose character is
borne out on forged out of warp he's the
right person to follow to those times
but uh it gives him a lot of sharp edges
as well he's not like any other people
because I'm playing that side on it
I'm trying not to look or sound like any
previous captain or a to come
fair enough now I'm going to go off
script a little bit I know there was a
lot of backlash against the show for
amount of diversity that the show was
showcasing in its casting and a lot of
negativity online negativity online but
going back to City Hall and and some of
the producers you guys have take this
one like this has been part of the Star
Trek universe from the beginning let's
not forget first interracial kiss MTV
was on Star Trek the original series
so we're forging new territory with a
diversity of cast and at storylines both
with race and sexual orientation can see
when you started making something here
from one of the number of us producers
on one of our incomparable reducers will
come in term as well but yeah it's
starting as always a tutorial of
diversity and of universality and of
unity and so you know as I said before I
just I truly believe it is one of the
main reasons why it is so important to
so many people still to this day and if
you say you love the legacy of Star Trek
but you don't love that and you've
missed it
and I and I encourage you to join join
with us
you know I'm saying come with a journey
with it hopefully it will help you learn
something about yourself and the people
around you that's what our story does
it's a confusing the degree of backlash
that we got because if you love science
fiction then you love imagining yourself
as something of other and Star Trek is
built around empathy
I mean uniquely when it comes to
long-standing science fiction if its
primary grammar that we see how we are
the same and we accept each other's
differences and find common ground and
love and it spoke more to what's
happening culturally on the internet
that again to Star Trek because Star
Trek means just about how we hold hands
and go forward together myself growing
up watching the original series the
unique brought very vision for the
future of mankind was so inspiring to me
even at age five when I started watching
it like oh you mean the human race can
do this like we can all get along and
not only get along with the different
races on our planet but see yourself as
human beings on a much greater journey
in the universe we can get along with
other species even and deal with race
and racism and different kinds of issues
in with other in other galaxies that was
anything you want me to go in life and
it's kind of weird that people have
something
with a woman leadership I heard there's
a woman got to do about a crushing
failure
well things have a rebuttal in Germany
and when we get woman president here the
whole full house will be completely
[Applause]
Gretchen we got a store question for you
from the internet
correct Thornton Co Co as a Miss
Colorado he had a question of the
klingons because in this we're at war
with the Klingons right 10 years before
the original series with a Klingons in
Star Trek discovery speak in English or
going on with subtitles and can you tell
us a little more about the Klingon
universe Frank thanks for your question
the because of the story were telling
about the Klingon in the season of Star
Trek it was very important for us to
have the Klingon speak Klingon and you
know there you know the very beginning
when out Brian started working on his
version of Star Trek it was important
for them to make sure that we see the
Klingons and exploit lead in a way and
then they weren't just sort of like
those of the universe and they have
their own pride under own inches of town
and their big very uh it's a very
fascinating culture the more weeks or
more part of it is really isn't an ethic
and I hope you guys know it's know you
Wilson a really just being able to
expand upon what was already set up
the knowledge of this group of
individuals in fantastic so yes there
will be you'll have to get out your
glasses will be reading nothing and
they're using the things coming on that
people get married to and yeah I got
convention yet speaking coming me okay
well your Klingon Hawk Bromwich yes
now it's don't really get an
understanding on you will understand we
hope in the my yeah we have someone
who's like if we as we're cutting if one
who just lines or anything it goes
through a filter all the time to make
sure that every word is correct so
there's someone policing this all the
time and hopefully if we've made mistake
we apologize we've gone to great lengths
to be incredibly accurate with our clean
up that would be an awesome job to be
Klingon interpreter for a TV oh yeah
right you guys know Doug Jones saw an
exceptional actor who has transformed
themselves in all kinds of incredible
characters what you do is just singular
and I love what you brought to so I say
right did tell us about creating Saru I
understand he has a special walk thing
Elmo would love to know about species
what do they call that gremlins or the
coop what do they go help you help you
with Kremlin proprietary collar bring it
go ahead blast as they kelpy on what you
have not seen in any trailer yet is my
foot where my feet are actually close so
I'm built up about aiding I'm six eight
in the show I'm the tallest character in
the show because I mean this is high
heeled position with no heel under there
so I'm balancing on the balls of my feet
what that what that did is that push my
head kind of pushes my pelvis forward to
keep my balance and so I can't show you
how to walk Fred
my tulip supermodel you sure it's not a
Kardashian clothes but I as as a
supermodel I get to keep my Tom my tall
skinny is we're celebrating like : my
skinny project and now our spectrum
uniforms are incredibly tight and snug
and my first costume fitting may I talk
about that for a second as most positive
things go for me there was a cluster of
people looking at the gun once that all
of the discussion about my plaque and so
I said you talking about my ass aren't
you know we can are so I think you want
to Pat it don't you yeah we kind of do I
said well he was up ssin if you've had
it a little more human it might look
hotter but it could be more human
let's celebrate the alien that I really
come in the room with so they
and favorite and favorite me rap
probably from being in rent
Daisy confused so many other classes
half purple underscore slob button a
person on Twitter at and this person as
can you tell us about your character and
will your character get to have romantic
relationships in the tall grass and that
question Rainn Wilson because I can
announce I've been given permission
because we're under lock and key being
able to you know not spoil anything but
we're going to release the information
that a wonderful actor that I've known
for over 20 years
that you would all know that you're old
enough to know remember that show my
so-called life he was in that show and
in the upcoming season of 13 visas why
and he's pregnant I actually did rent
with briefly in the long course of my
life with it Wilson Cruz he would be
playing your what Mama's my love
interest my partner yeah and we are both
are so no luck you have a mammoth and
we're both officers on the ship as yes
of my part my character lieutenant is
the first openly gay Curtain history of
the TV
Honda what that I'm very proud of it is
all I wanted to say
anyway sizes now you had on the set a
couple of times you have some incredible
mouthfuls a Holford is this 21st century
types of it gobbledy Joker what do you
remember any of us any of that I did
prepare this so you know because I was
born that this might happen so we begin
with all things with the mushroom in
this case prototype cities still at the
Ettore species made up of exotic matter
found not only in an our dimension but
also in a discrete subspace domain known
as the mycelium Network God is horrified
trips off the tongue question for the
group what no that's sorry I'm sorry I
got me they got a TV comedy actor to be
here it's let's move this was going to
do it but he's deep in the boiling miss
mussels in a Jacuzzi full of hundred
dollar bills
Sonique well how would you describe a
seven-year relationship between a
Michael and Captain George you played by
Michelle Yeoh yeah oh don't we love
Michelle Yeoh you guys
about a woman it is a very close
relationship I graduated from the Vulcan
client Academy and went to the Shinto
straight out of college eventually and
she took me under her wing and I
basically was committed to her through
I'm really excited to see this through
my surrogate dad Sarek a little bit of a
room filled so you know I was raised on
Vulcan by him and Amanda and after the
murder of my parents and so he basically
committed committed me to her and I grow
tremendously her to religion and we are
very close this is very close
relationships very similar to mother and
daughter fantastic
and speaking of their gym spring hello
big big fan of yours have so many
different things you could opinion and
so excited to see your Sara how does
yours here and in to the previous
portrayals of Sarek well it's um it's an
exploration of who he was with younga we
know where he ends up but one of the
things that was always fascinating was
the fact that he marriage with you
and that's sports back story but that's
fascinating of a thing for a Vulcan to
do like it was inscribed so we're kind
of unpeeling the layers of who he might
have been and it's sort of being
revealed with each episode and um he's a
mentor to Michael and has taken her
under his wing and so that's interesting
too he has a full human child to raise I
finally to be endlessly fascinating and
complex and
[Laughter]
can you tell us a little more about how
you find them to be complexed through
now I'm asking about man like genuinely
I'm interested well because the whole
Vulcan ideal is something that they
evolved over centuries and the reality
is that they still do have emotion and
they had to cope with these emotions and
there's a real struggle I think that
goes on in Zurich with that because he's
brought a human into his life and now he
has a heart human child and the fully
human child this is very challenging
them and I think it kind of opened up a
door in him that he didn't know was that
see that's good we get an immediate
answer right tricyclic so I suspected
some brains are exploding at the idea
that Derek has actively that this box
has ever mentioned in Canada and just be
patient with us we're aware you'll see
where it's going but we are saying this
would get Dallas there's a lot of weird
nonsensical online rivalry between the
Star Wars universe and the Star Trek
universe now that we here at comic-con
how do you how do you address how do you
address that
well it's our Tech's just better
[Applause]
any other producers want to think that I
just think it's preposterous because you
can like both it's like saying well I'm
excited for the new Blade Runner
well arrival is better the universe in
which all these things can exist they're
trying to do two very different things
actually the real answer to questions is
the truth is I started as a Star Wars
person before I became a Star Trek
person as a kid and have very deep
relationships that both of those things
now and I think that what's happening to
both universes is really quite beautiful
because as they expand and as these
stories grow we get to dig into aspects
of the stories that were mentioned
peripherally you know we wrote one being
a sentence from Star Wars that became
its own film you know and the the level
of diversity of the characters in the
world that are exploding in front of us
are so exciting that I have always felt
there is place for both you can love
both and you can love both equally for
very very different reasons they're
about very different things so in a
weird way is that was an oranges but I I
do respect those of the war between them
in this sense and you know of course if
people want to inside they should choose
Star Trek Jason you I've been with you
and you've been kind of mopped by Harry
Potter fans there are out there power
now you're going into the Star Trek
universe have you noticed any difference
between the two fan groups is very few
the Star Trek fans want to sleep with my
son don't really say long stories I mean
that the Star Trek fans are some of them
have been back to 15 years so they're
jelly older than the mother times but
the same level of of passion also of
being for some people released or saved
by storage
these are the funds of a faculty in fact
as wells but but we lived complication
and challenging life that we look to
stories often to help us navigate our
way through difficult times and I Star
Trek if a lot of people's done over the
years I think I hopefully will do it and
I know that wanted that and so what I
see is those standards both of them I
think is people who have found something
more than similarly light but something
that meant something or very profound
and I just started making the check
easily cause we do we the rest of you
wherever you are hear from everyone and
Shahzad merry memory can human you ever
heard you guys yet what's something
about when you undertook that there
really surprised you about going into
this particular facet of the Star Trek
universe well for me is when you get a
job you expect it to be just about the
sci-fi when you're closer you get start
wrapping this we start thinking about
the technology you know that for me was
enjoyable to play and is enjoyment
layers the emotional complexity of
everything we're doing just there's so
much emotion the show it's very lot of
time with the character than us and then
at first as we want to we want to do to
love the boatman's great and is there
something you think will be surprising
for fans surprising to you and what what
will be surprising for fans you guys
don't know how get out stupidly funny
this one is that you guys are gonna like
really impress a lot of birdies cut off
Broadway fans but you seriously
[Music]
saying I did I guess both something that
made it really great and something that
was surprising with how much it means to
so many people and how that endow a
hacker with respect for the story and
and wanting to give you the best
possible product it it lends power to
everything you do to know how much the
people around you are invested in it
that's great
anyone else order there are many I think
one of the great advantages for us is
that because every episode doesn't have
to because then is it because we are you
know a streaming format it isn't just
that there's emotional serialization is
that their story serialization which
allows for a lot of really interesting
twists and turns sometimes the things
you think are happening we're not
exactly what are really happening and
there are big big reveals at several
points over the course of the season and
I think the fun of it is that in every
possible way we all look to draw those
reveals from from the origins of fact
but I think you find a lot of surprises
along the way the fans will certainly be
debating as we as we go on
I found surprisingly not going to make
any difference to the audience but we
all adore each other we spend a lot of
time together on still work but also
snicker is between on the set and the
culture and all that's there but
people's where everybody whatever level
they play in the crew everybody's equal
when we play games night I stunned by
this incredibly generous timelessness is
one of those fiercely competitive
uncompetitive government it's not
surprised this is
Vinglish document you were following
battling other but don't play a game
okay and you guys have to understand
like Sumitra juice me is one of the
kindest most radiant
generous to let ever met in my life
right great
I'm not I'm pretty old I've met a lot of
people and she really is up there I was
only on set for a couple of episodes but
so how did you guys producers how did
you find her
how did you know that she was Mike
Wernham and out of the emotional core
the heart of the of the story you were
going to be telling what was that
process like that was a really difficult
process for all of us because you know
that person doesn't just walk in the
room and we we knew what we wanted on
the page the role is complex and not
just anybody to play it and we was
looking and looking and looking and
looking for months and months and her
name came up and she was available
acting in quest
never much juice busy on this small show
thank you sir oh yeah and she live a
little and suddenly we had to push a
little bit and she became available the
second she walked in the door Gretchen
and I turned to each other and were just
like that's it that's Michael Burton
right there and she left and it was
basically call call call CBS founder
founded achievement how can she kind and
wonderful hand give nothing the games
done
[Music]
thank thank you and thank you raised to
saying that you I think see you back
home what everyone has been so kindly
and graciously thank you in I have been
so surprised to see how quickly we've
come together and build a family and we
have just congealed so beautifully and
to you and she but you know we become
cohesive unit let's go with that when
it's real
but yeah it's always been so important
to me that we obviously value the story
in value the show but value of each
other and realize that we are all doing
this together we all have to share and
then it expands beyond us to you that
you know you are a part of this we are
all in this together we are one
community and that has been the most
beautiful thing to see because we truly
are I mean that crown panel we truly are
so grateful to be here be a part to be
endowed which is with this legacy is
shown coming on oh yeah we are very
excited thank you for hey no too much
time left I want to take a couple of
questions from the audience
considering much of what's going on on
this planet today what happened your
biggest challenges in developing Star
Trek discovery while also establishing a
clear resonance with the egalitarian
messages that were key in Gene
Roddenberry's original vision for Star
Trek without coming across as preachy or
too predictable
last question ever
oh thank you could you repeat that
booyah
there is something that is a key to
understanding at least my understanding
our understanding of the original
Roddenberry universe and that is the
attempt to establish family that despite
how disparate cultures and people may be
the formation of family and a family
choose is a transcendent value and what
is lovely about that is there's truth to
it that you can serve without being
earnest you can actually chase
connection you can chase companionship
you can chase a feeling of belonging
especially in science fiction and really
stumble along the way because part of
what we serve in retrospective the idea
of no conflict and start record of
course that's nonsense there's always
been conflict in Star Trek and so our
opportunity is to take our view of
conflict today more psychologically real
more human or longer storytelling form
and still search for some resolution
that is not dystopian but utopian
excellent Villa lady oh yes hi my name
is Julia I'm actually up here though on
the house of my mother who couldn't be
here today but it has been of pens and
the very first episode
in the sixties so she wanted me to know
she wanted me to ask sorry is there
anything in particular that you've been
anxious or apprehensive or excited how
knowing that Star Trek is such a part of
popular culture and has been for so long
I'm an anxious for people to see what
we're doing because every time I open
the script and it's sent to me I'm as a
fan myself thrilled with what I'm
reading
and then thrilled with what I get the
chance to be a part of that I just it's
like we you know I I was backstage like
weeping in the trailer like this is a
glimpse of what we're doing and I'm just
I feel like I'm just so excited to share
the world like we're on the cusp of that
it's happening soon and I know it might
seem yet we're all hired to do this this
is part of our job I promise you that we
passionately believe in what we're doing
and we passionately believe that we are
trying to do something that is
meaningful and that will honor what came
before so I'm just I'm personally
excited for people to experience that I
just want to say too that just coming in
for a couple of episodes buddy in
reading some of the scripts these
producers and writers they went for it
okay that does not show where they're
playing it safe in any way shape or form
they're going out there with with plots
and ideas and emotion and character
intricacy like I've never seen it in a
trek in Arabian before so you guys get
ready
it's pretty awesome yeah one of my
favorite things about Star Trek is the
great character relationships and I'm
wondering what friendships and rival
we'll expect to see in the new series I
think of it as a we can tell you
everything that happens you wouldn't
have to bother watching it tonight but
it's full of nothing but characters and
then it's true that we have these
amazing sets and special effects for me
to think what happens between the three
humans of the humans and the aliens what
happens between the characters is where
the real drama is and there's every
shade of everything and you know it's an
equals character actor Michael Underwood
you're going to see the show through her
eyes having a relationship with
everybody on the ship in some way base
or shape or form and I'd really very
much enjoyed my brothers sister were
sort of relationship with her we're too
different we're in completely different
worlds that we're we're both upwardly
mobile and nothing the officer rankings
and so we're very competitive
it's very compassionate toward one
another on really enjoyed that on-screen
relationship very much I think there's a
lot more sort of dynamic nature to the
relationships than maybe there's been in
past trends where you know we're in the
original series there was that sort of
dynamic between Spock and bones it was
always there I think that the nature of
our if we have edginess between each
other two different times it evolved or
ships you know in ways that aren't
always just playing the same beats over
and over over these characters and
what's been great about the stories I
was latitude that we've been able to
have was to really you know drill down
on the characters and these characters
are not fully formed out of the gate and
I think what's been so fun about it is
to watch you know through through some
inquisitive Michaels eyes stepping onto
his ship and you know trying to find
herself and trying to find friends and
trying to find love and Gretchen and I
always look at every show we work on
from the standpoint that it's a family
show at the workplace you know and that
the science fiction lays over the top
and that the other thing that's really
great about the serialized component
those relationships continue to change
and pull through and it's been really
fun to to get to create with these
characters we have we have it we have a
ball you know just just watching the
relationships of all let's give it up
[Applause]
you